over here what would you like to hear a
rapper fact we've done good if you were
older I would fight you that is a that's
a great suggestion let me down
there we go pinch on earn you a fan I
protect you like it your buddies does
your buddies nodding his head y-yeah
it's all pretty spiffy haircut I like it
cool Kim jong-un for those who don't
know he's the leader of North Korea
which actually trying to take you on
holiday it's great Kim jong-un is the
first suggestion he goes over here watch
let's hear a rap about hang glider you a
hang glider sir why do the person next
to you you just wait that's just
ridiculous
okay go what would you suggest your mum
great the suggestion is your mum hang
gliding great we'll combine those make
it better dunno I'll go inspect you're
talking to a teenager right guys over
here what you guys let's hear a rap
about bad hair day is that a pointed
attack on me
I'm a man we don't have bad hair day we
just have days right kick jump on your
mum hang gliding a bad hair day you put
your hand up there we have a suggestion
or you saying I'm having a pretty great
hair day Chris your hat is on point
buddy I like it bad hair day bad hair
day your mom hang-gliding
min-jeong good guys over here what's
going on here a rack back Wow some real
planet either you've got a psychic link
or there was some discussion before that
netball are you all on netball team cool
what this is you play
WVU say that as if I know what those
letters stand for wait - thanks cool are
you impressed the man you want netball
positions are my mum played netball
professionally which means you didn't
really get paid it's not what zip
there's not real thought
just say that it guys know that ball is
amazing sport it's a great suggestion
netball we simply playing wing defense
your mama hang gliding bad hair day kim
jeong-hoon I'm gonna take one final
suggestion this can come from anywhere
but it has to be the best one so far you
can't let the side down because so far
they feel pretty good
diamonds on the sole of your shoes
netball must play pretty well then great
diamonds on the soles of your shoes that
genuinely is one of the most fantastic
is getting up at a church which is not
really saying much but I like it
your suggestions that remind you all
enjoy on your mum hang gliding bad hair
day netball specifically wing defence
and diamonds on the soul of my shoes
this game I mean if that's what you
laugh like you're gonna love the next
three minutes it's going to be amazing
as I said this is a freestyle rap made
entirely on the spot never to be seen
again never been seen before and do not
worry it will not be anywhere near as it
turns it's the embarrassingly totally
bad as you are expecting a privately
educated middle-class white British boy
to be how we do our
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]